CHAITALI NARLA: Hi, everyone.
Our topic of the day
is Mindful Testing--
Balancing Test Coverage
and Maintenance.
Before we dive into the topic,
a quick introduction to us.
My name is Chaitali, and
I'm an engineering manager
in Google Cloud's Engineering
Productivity Organization.
SHADI KHALEK: Hello, everyone.
My name is Shadi.
I'm an engineering manager
in Google Cloud's Engineering
Productivity Organization, too.
CHAITALI NARLA: So today,
we'll be talking to you
about what is mindful testing.
We also would like
to talk to you
about why mindful testing is
an important concept that you
could practice in
your organization,
and what benefit
that would give you.
We will talk about
five tips on how you
can practice mindful testing.
Along the way, we'll
talk about various tools
and processes we use at Google
and especially in Google Cloud
to apply mindful
testing to our products.
So reading from the definition
in the Oxford Dictionary,
mindfulness is the
quality or state
of being conscious or
aware of something.
So what is mindful testing?
To understand this, let's
talk about integration testing
to which the concept of mindful
testing applies the most.
We know that integration
tests are a complex system.
We know that we have to
constantly balance trade-offs
between too many tests
and too few tests when
it comes to integration tests.
If you have too many
integration tests,
you may have great
coverage of your product,
but your release
lifecycle might be slowed.
If you have too few tests, you
may be releasing very quickly,
but at the cost possibly
of reliability and velocity
of your system.
We also know that
tests have a lifecycle.
If you want to
add a new feature,
you may need to add new tests.
If you change or
deprecate a feature,
you may need to change
your deprecate the tests
that you have.
So in summary,
what we believe is
tests can help you
improve product quality,
but only through
thoughtful care.
So going back to mindful
testing, how do we define that?
We define it as
the art and science
of writing and maintaining
just the right amount of tests
that give you enough
product coverage.
Why mindful testing?
There are four
reasons that we would
like to present to you about my
mindful testing is important.
The first one is reliability.
You want to find those bugs
before your customers do.
You also want to
make sure that you
are delivering a stable
and dependable product
to your customers.
Mindful testing can help
you provide that reliably.
Our second reason
is time to market.
If you want faster
time to market
for your features
in your product,
mindful testing can
help you achieved that
with a good balance between
too many and too few tests.
The third reason is technical
debt and reducing debt.
And the fourth reason is
developer productivity.
Both of these, the
third and fourth reason,
are great reasons to make sure
your engineers are happier,
and who doesn't want that?
So hopefully,
we've convinced you
that mindful testing is an
interesting concept that
can help you and your
products overall.
Let's talk about five
tips for mindful testing.
SHADI KHALEK: We
will present to you
five useful tips
to achieve mindful
testing that we
continuously tried
to adopt for our teams
and our products here.
To start with,
listen to your tests.
When they fail, they are telling
you something very important.
Now to listen to
your tests and be
able to take action
when they fail,
you need to start
with a setup that
has high signal-to-noise ratio.
At Google, we do this by
ensuring that every failure
type has an owner.
And we have routing tools that
automatically route failures
correctly to the
corresponding team.
For example, at GCE, integration
end-to-end test failure
could be routed to the control
plane, the virtualization,
the [INAUDIBLE] OS or the
kernel team, and so on.
Also, we want to take immediate
action when failures happen.
We achieve this by
setting response SLOs
to our test failures.
And we do this by having
bug master rotations
from different teams to
keep an eye on the builds
when they fail.
We also have a philosophy
of roll back first
and investigate later.
We have playbooks
that developers
follow to make their job
easier in investigating
those failures.
In addition, we need to
follow up on large scale test
breakages with postmortems.
The postmortem analysis
look into how could we
prevent such breakages
from happening again
and how could we shift
our testing to the left.
And also, our
philosophy here is write
the smallest test possible.
We try to apply the same
rigor of production outages
to our test outages,
especially the integration
and end-to-end tests.
Help your tests stay healthy.
They need to help
developing good habits.
The first habit
we try to develop
is running on hermetic
test infrastructure
versus non-hermetic ones.
And familiar test
environments allow your tests
to run in isolation, be
repeatable, and easier
to debug.
Here, this is an
example of KIND,
which is Kubernetes-in-Docker
as a system in a box test
infrastructure.
It enables you to
run hermetic tests
and it allows you
to run integration
tests for Kubernetes, Istio,
or Anthos application.
The environment here
would be isolated
with no external dependencies
and be completely familiar.
We also want to ensure
that tests clean up
after themselves.
Now this is needed mostly when
we share the test environment
across different tests.
We know that setting up a
hermetic and familiar test
environment is not possible
for every single test suite,
either because of
the cost or because
of the complexity of systems.
So in those cases, where we
are sharing a test environment
across different
test suites, we need
to make sure that we clean
up every single test run
and we keep the shared
environment in a good state.
To enable compute engine tests
to clean up after themselves
effectively, we create the
tools as project rental service.
This allows GCE developers
to use fewer test projects
to run their integration tests.
As a test starts to run,
they would go and run
the project out of
a pool of projects.
They would use the project
to do any testing needed.
And then when they
are done, they
would return the
project to the service.
Now the service is responsible
of cleaning up the project,
deleting all
resources, and setting
the project back to a
clean slate, which could be
used again for other testing.
This separates the test
from the cleanup needed,
and guarantees
that the cleanup is
done effectively and correctly.
We also want to invest in root
causes and debugging tools.
No matter what environment we're
running again, either if it's
hermetic or shared
environment, we need good root
causing and debugging tools.
For example, tools
like Cloud Debugger
can help you significantly
in debugging your cloud
application.
CHAITALI NARLA: The target
is to discipline your test
with respect, because sometimes,
they will try your patience.
Our strategy for having healthy
tests, the cornerstone of this,
is to manage flakiness.
Let's talk a little bit about
why managing flakiness is
an important tool.
Consider a microservices
architecture
with about 40
critical components.
If each of those components
is only to 0.26% flaky,
you would still get an overall
environmental flakiness of 10%.
To get an overall environment
flakiness of about 1.5%,
which is a good standard for
being able to release products
quickly, you would still
need each component
to have just 0.38% flakiness.
So hopefully, this shows
you why managing flakiness
is critical for us.
We manage flakiness
with two approaches.
One is that we track flakiness
numbers really closely,
so we know when and where
and how blindness shows up
in our integration tests.
Here's an example of a graph
that one of our metrics tools
generated.
As you can see here,
it shows a 90 day trend
for not only how much flakiness
is present in our systems,
but also, the number
of test targets
that were affected
by this flakiness.
So this is an example of
this and many other metrics
we track around flakiness
to help us understand
how to combat it better.
We also invest in long
term flakiness pictures.
This is an example of a before
and after from a flakiness
fix it.
As you can see, the
before has a lot
more inconsistency at
flakiness while the after
looks a lot more consistent
in terms of the test
results we see there.
Fixes are a longtime
tradition at Google,
where teams will set aside
time from their regular work
for up to a week
or more sometimes
to focus on engineering
excellence teams.
And flakiness is a very
popular theme to focus on.
So in summary, we
discipline our tests
by managing flakiness, tracking
it, and making sure that we
prioritize long term fixes.
SHADI KHALEK: Teach
your tests independence,
so you don't have to tend
to their needs often.
We really want to
lower the maintenance
cost of all our tests.
Maintaining the tests
is very expensive,
so we start with proper
capacity planning.
We need to provide
adequate resources
to run our tests
quickly and correctly.
At Google, we do this by taking
inventory of all our test
resources needed once a year
to make sure that the existing
tests could run properly,
and also, to ensure that we
have enough capacity
during the coming
year for additional tests.
The graph here shows you why
capacity planning is important
and measuring is
important, as well.
Here, we could see that there
is an amount of unused resources
for running that single test.
We could reduce the resources
allocated for that test
so that we could run
either more tests
or we could increase the
parallelism of our testing,
and reduce the time
to finish the tests.
Write-once run-anywhere
is our philosophy
to get the maximum
out of your tests,
especially when you're
dealing with integration
end-to-end testing.
This allows you to run
tests against different test
environments and to
validate them quicker.
Anthos this is an example
of such an infrastructure
that follows the
[INAUDIBLE] paradigm.
It allows you to run your
application and the tests
either on prem or
on the public cloud.
At Google, we also invest a lot
in smart test infrastructure.
For example, machine
learning-based presubmits
that run fewer targeted tests
instead of the whole test
suites based on
different signals,
especially from the change
list being submitted.
This will reduce the amount of
resources needed to run only
at the same time, keeping a
high confidence of our test
coverage and the signal.
Also, automatic
capacity planning,
where we could automatically
reduce the resources needed
per test run and reuse those
resources for other runs.
We need to spend a lot of time
with our tests and our test
infrastructure.
We start with
proper maintenance.
And here, I'm talking about
maintaining our critical user
journeys and tracking feature
coverage for our tests.
To give you an example, the
GCE Live Migration feature
presented here is
mapped to certain CUJs
that we have tests to cover.
Those tests are tracked and
we have automatic tooling
to track the coverage
based on the CUJs for GCE.
This helps us keep
focus on where testing
is needed the most, and
in preventing regressions
in CUJ test coverage.
We know that CUJ testing,
especially integration
end-to-end, are
very costly, and we
want to make the best
use of our testing.
We also need to keep an
eye on upgrading our test
infrastructure to
new technologies that
could allow us to run
tests faster or debug them
or maintain them better.
At Google, we do this
by having core teams
responsible of common test
infrastructure that is used
across different Google teams.
For example, we have a common
system integration test
framework that
allows us to benefit
from any improvements the
team does on that test
infrastructure and
allow us to move quickly
to new technologies.
We also want to look into adding
more test coverage and test
features as we see appropriate.
And here, we are
focusing on follow ups
on production outages, where
we do an analysis on what
testing is needed to prevent
those outages from happening
again.
And also, based
on customer issues
or on test outages themselves.
As I said, big
test outages could
lead to more testing, different
pieces in the pipeline,
especially moving left
through the development cycle.
Also, we need to look into
deleting and deprecating
our tests.
This is needed when
features are deprecated
or when critical user journeys'
priorities are changed.
And by that, we need to
keep an eye on that testing
that we are running,
and deprecate them,
or change the flow we run them.
CHAITALI NARLA: So
those were the five tips
that we wanted to
share with you.
We have a couple of
key takeaways for you
from our talk.
The first one is
that mindful testing
can help change your
organization's culture
to focus on healthy and
regularly cared for tests.
The second takeaway
we have for you
is that mindful
testing will really
help you get more return on
investment from your test.
We wanted to give a shout out to
two docs from Cloud Next 2019.
Both of these have a deep dive
into the different concepts
that we talked about
to date, and they also
talk about how you can apply
these concepts and thereby,
mindful testing, by using
the different products we
have available on the
Google Cloud platform.
So do check them out.
That's all we have to
share with you today.
Thank you so much for
listening to our talk.
SHADI KHALEK: Thank you
all for listening to us.
Please give us
feedback on how you
apply mindful testing
in your organization
and if you find
these tips useful.
Thank you.